liverpool will be the first uk
city to roll out mass testing anyone who
lives or works here will be able to
access a covid test
multiple times even if they're not
showing symptoms
the only way that we're going to allow
this kind of national depression
to lift is when we get to the point
where we can basically test the whole
population
every month and i don't think we're too
far away from that we're on half a
million tests a day that would need
about 2 million tests a day
this could be a big step towards that
and i think that's the moment when we
can start thinking about life getting
back to normal
the military will help with this pilot
which includes tests that give results
within an
hour nhs test and trace is more
efficient the faster the results
but it's still just one part of the
system
i think the important thing is that if
tests are going to be done
in a quick manner that the tracing and
isolating system
is up to speed to be able to deal with
that at the moment we've still got
over 40 percent of people not even being
contacted by
the circo run system so having all these
tests done
is not going to be of any use unless
people are actually contacted by that
system afterwards
every day you see teams of doctors and
nurses
going above and beyond the call of duty
liverpool was the first city region to
be moved into tier three
and hospitals here are under pressure
this video was published by liverpool
city council
they're putting their lives at risk
every single day
[Music]
the voice you're hearing is joe anderson
the city's mayor
it's a real reminder really of the
health and safety risks that our
hospital
staff are taking every single day and
every single shift
what happens here is important for
everywhere
with no certainty about a vaccine this
pilot will assess
if mass testing with isolating drives
down infections
if it works millions more tests could be
deployed to other areas
before christmas catherine over totsi
sky news